[Music]
great music for that story while her
husband was serving in the Navy overseas
the California mom was secretly carrying
their child well we showed you yesterday
huh Natasha Daugherty surprised her
husband Chris with the pregnancy when he
returned home Jamie yuccas spoke with a
couple to learn the challenges of
keeping the baby a secret for six months
when Chris Daugherty came home from
deployment his wife Natasha gave him the
surprise of his life and she dropped the
sign and I was like whoa what is that
and then I hope the belly because I was
thinking maybe she was playing a trick
on me she had one of those I don't know
the belly was real Natasha was eight
months pregnant she found out just after
he left for his six-month deployment but
keeping the secret was tough she had to
strategically cover up her tummy and
family photos she shared with Chris I
just kept telling my four-year-old I was
getting fat because because I didn't
hide she's a little chatterbox working
two jobs and trying to raise three
children there were moments she wanted
the blab but did it then Chris was sent
to the Korean Peninsula
where tensions were high was there ever
a moment though that you thought gee
he's kind of in a tricky part of the
world right now should I be telling him
yes the deployment was only supposed to
be like five months and then they're
like Oh turning around like I was
definitely questioning like should I
tell him because if something happens
I'm I'm gonna feel guilty and I'll
worked out it is yep she did wait to
find out the baby's sex the moment Chris
got home they threw a gender-reveal
party Chris will be there for his
daughter's birth before he's deployed
again sometime next year what surprise
are you gonna have next time
as happy as Chris was with his wife
surprise
once was enough for CBS this morning
Jamie yuccas Temecula California I
thought that was a nice surprise but I
was outnumbered at the table because
both of you thought that ain't funny
yeah but the lead of that story is is
she's got two jobs and she's rigged
those kids on her own as her husband is
off serving his country for six months
great reminder of how great our men and
women
and their family are as it turned out
okay